Hey--howwzit going bros
My name is *pause* POODIEPAAH (oml it's been so long)
and this is a really tough video~
Just don't come to my house please. (damn that's tough)
Are we done?
*Looks back at ainsley-kun* Are we done? That was it
I think this video will be some sort of Public Service  Announcement, where I speak for many, if not all, YouTubers.
Also, saying what should be obvious.
So, realleh, i don't kno wuts da point.
Since I started doing YouTube, I've lived in sex (PAPA PEWDS STRIKES AGAIN) was gonna go seven or six and then it went "sex"
That's pretty funny (agreed)
I lived in sex (six) different locations and I've had "fans" coming up to each and every single one of them.
And here's the big surprise *judgeful stare* it's fucking weird.
It's so weird, it's SOO. Fucking weird.
It's so weird, it's UGHH UGHAA
Just stop.
Picture it like this:
I don't know who you are, but I know that you found my address online and thought, "Hey, I'm going to invite myself over."
From my perspective, that's just insane.
I've even had parents coming over with their kids (have they actually WATCHED ur videos?)
I've had people yell outside my house
I've had school classes come outside.
Just because you found my address, it doesn't mean you found an invitation for you to come over. (but lowkey it does)
This should be obvious.
And I know a lot of people will say:
"WELL
YoUr A YoUtUbeR
YoU sIgNeD uP fOr DiS liFe
NoW yOu GoTtA DeAl WiF iT"
And it's like, "No, foh-fuck, no. Okay?"
Just because I have an audience, it doesn't mean I have to be okay with bad behavior. That's soo stupid.
And I also know that videos like these tend to make people think, " Well, he really doesn't really care about his fans, does it (it?)"
So, don't get me wrong *imaginary beatboxing*, I love meeting you bros. <3
99% of the time, it's an amazing experience, and it makes me understand that what I do here, every single day in front of the computer,
has real impact,
and that's something I never want taken away.
*hugs rare pokemon* But, if you do come to my house, I would not greet you and I will not take a picture with you
and if you came from really far away, well I'm sorry, you shouldn't have done that.
This is about my privacy, and I think if you bros were in the same situation, you would want the same thing for yourself.
So, thank you for understanding.
Don't come to, uh, YouTubers' houses because it's weird and uuh... thank you guys so much, love you guys so much, and as always...
*don't you marina joyce me now*
(pewds if you need help breath in your next video)
#savepapapewds #dixout4harambe
i do not like ricegum